EE.UU. empata en lectura en el puesto 15,
pero en ciencia es el 23, y en matemática el 31.
Solo hay un área en la que estamos casi en la cima,
y es en no dar a nuestros profesores
la ayuda necesaria para que desarrollen sus habilidades.
Analicemos los sistemas que tienen mejor rendimiento académico:
la provincia de Shanghái, China.
Ocupa el primer lugar en todas las áreas:
en lectura, matemática y ciencias,
y una de las claves del éxito increíble de Shanghái
es la forma en la que promueve la mejora en los profesores.
Se aseguran de que los profesores más jóvenes
tengan la oportunidad de ver trabajar a profesores magistrales.
Tienen grupos de estudio semanales
donde se reúnen los profesores a hablar de lo que funciona.
Incluso solicitan que cada profesor analice
y dé retroalimentación a sus colegas.
Se preguntarán por qué es tan importante un sistema así.
Porque en la enseñanza
hay mucha variabilidad.
Algunos profesores son mucho más efectivos que otros.
De hecho, hay profesores en todo el país
que ayudan a sus estudiantes a obtener logros extraordinarios.
Si hoy el profesor medio
llegase a igualar a esos profesores,
nuestros estudiantes arrasarían al resto del mundo.
Por eso necesitamos un sistema que ayude a nuestros profesores
a ser lo mejor de lo mejor.
¿Cómo sería ese sistema?
Bueno, para averiguarlo, nuestra fundación
ha trabajado con 3000 profesores
en distritos de todo el país
en un proyecto llamado Métricas de la Enseñanza Eficaz [MEE].
Pusimos observadores a ver videos
de profesores en el aula
para que los calificaran en una serie de prácticas.
Por ejemplo, ¿le hicieron a sus estudiantes
preguntas estimulantes?
¿Encontraron múltiples formas de explicar una idea?
También le pedimos a los estudiantes que respondieran un cuestionario:
"¿Sabe tu profesor
cuándo la clase entiende una lección?"
"¿Aprendes a corregir tus errores?"
Y hallamos cosas interesantes.
Primero, los profesores a los que les fue bien
obtenían mucho mejores resultados estudiantiles.
Eso nos dicta que hicimos las preguntas correctas.
Y, segundo, los profesores del programa nos dijeron
que estos videos y encuestas de los alumnos
fueron herramientas de diagnóstico muy útiles,
porque señalaron lugares específicos
que podían mejorarse.
Quiero mostrarles este video
del MEE en acción.
(Música)
(Video) Sarah Brown Wessling: Buenos días a todos.
Hablemos de lo que haremos hoy.
Para empezar, una revisión por pares, ¿sí?
Una revisión por pares, y el objetivo al final de la clase
es que puedan determinar
si tienen correcciones para sus ensayos.
Mi nombre es Sarah Brown Wessling.
Soy profesora de inglés de secundaria
en la Escuela Secundaria Johnston, de Johnston, Iowa.
Giren hacia alguien que esté cerca.
Díganle qué cadena lógica es necesario demostrar.
Creo que hay una diferencia para los profesores
entre lo abstracto de cómo vemos nuestra práctica
y luego la realidad concreta de la misma.
Bien, me gustaría que traigan sus artículos.
Creo que el video nos ofrece
un cierto grado de realidad.
Uno no puede negar lo que se ve en el video,
hay mucho que aprender de eso,
y hay muchas maneras de crecer
en la profesión viendo esto.
Tengo una cámara de video y un pequeño trípode
e invertí en esta pequeña lente gran angular.
Al principio de la clase coloco la cámara
en el fondo de la clase. No es una toma perfecta.
No capta todo lo que sucede.
Pero puedo oír el audio. Puedo ver mucho.
Puedo aprender mucho con el video.
De modo que ha sido una herramienta
simple pero potente para analizar la clase.
Bien, primero veamos la larga, ¿sí?
Cuando termino de grabar, lo pongo en la computadora,
lo repaso y tomo notas.
Si no escribo, no las recuerdo.
Así que tomar notas es parte de mi elaboración mental
y descubro cosas conforme escribo.
Me ha servido para mi crecimiento personal
y para mi propia reflexión sobre la estrategia de enseñanza,
la metodología, la gestión del aula
y los diferentes aspectos de la clase.
Me alegro de que ya se haya aplicado este método
para comparar, en cierto modo, lo que funciona y lo que no.
Creo que ese video expone
muchos elementos intrínsecos a la docencia
de forma que nos ayuda a entender,
y ayuda a la comunidad más amplia a entender,
de qué se trata en realidad este complejo trabajo.
Creo que es una forma de ilustrar
cosas que no se pueden transmitir en un plan de estudios,
cosas que no pueden transmitirse en una norma,
cosas que ni siquiera a veces se pueden transmitir
en un libro de pedagogía.
Muy bien, que tengan un buen fin de semana.
Hasta la próxima.
[Todas las clases pueden ser así]
(Aplausos)
Bill Gates: Nos gustaría que algún día las aulas de EE.UU.
sean como esa.
Pero todavía hay trabajo por hacer.
Diagnosticar las áreas de mejora docente
es la mitad de la batalla.
También tenemos que darles las herramientas necesarias
para actuar frente al diagnóstico.
Si uno sabe que tiene que mejorar
la forma de enseñar fracciones,
debería poder ver un video
de la persona que mejor enseña fracciones en el mundo.
Pero construir esta retroalimentación para el profesor
y mejorar el sistema no será fácil.
Por ejemplo, sé que algunos profesores
no se sienten inmediatamente cómodos con la idea
de una cámara en el aula.
Es comprensible, pero nuestra experiencia con MEE
sugiere que si el profesor gestiona el proceso,
si son ellos quienes graban las clases,
y ellos eligen los cursos que quieren publicar,
muchos estarán ansiosos de participar.
Construir este sistema requerirá además
una inversión considerable.
Nuestra fundación estima que podría costar
hasta USD 5000 millones.
Es una suma grande, pero puesta en perspectiva,
es menos del 2 %
de lo que se paga en salarios a los docentes.
Las ventajas para los profesores serían fenomenales.
Finalmente tendríamos una forma de darles retroalimentación
así como los medios para hacer algo al respecto.
Pero este sistema tendría
incluso un beneficio más importante para el país.
Nos colocaría en una senda segura
en la que nuestros estudiantes tendrían buena formación,
encontrarían una carrera satisfactoria y gratificante,
y tendrían la oportunidad de cumplir sus sueños.
Esto no solo mejoraría el éxito de nuestro país,
sino que lo haría más justo, también.
Estoy muy entusiasmado con la oportunidad
de darles a nuestros profesores el apoyo que quieren y merecen.
Espero que Uds. también.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)